[Musica]
salve a tutti io farò in questi minuti
un elogio della collaborazione
l'elogio è un discorso in cui si
decantano le virtù di qualcosa di
qualcuno ecco qui non c'è una persona di
cui io parlerò non c'è neanche un
oggetto ma è qualcosa di materiale ma è
concreto dentro di noi perché la
sentiamo perché è un processo sociale la
collaborazione è un modo di interagire
con le altre persone
stamattina l'abbiamo sentita citare fra
l'altro ecco la particolarità è che è
questa che viviamo noi tutti un epoca in
cui alleniamo solo uno delle nostre due
bracciano accusa questa immagine
uno dei nostri due muscoli e quello che
alleniamo di più è il braccio del
muscolo dell'individuo e della
competizione quindi farò un elogio della
collaborazione per dire che abbiamo
bisogno di allenare anche un'altra parte
perché è meglio quando le due braccia
sono ben sono ben bilanciati viviamo
un'epoca in cui siamo continuamente
sollecitati a appunto allenare una parte
il fatto di vivere in una società
individualista non è di per sé una cosa
brutta anzi vorrei togliere se me lo
concedete quel sapore moralistico della
parola individualista perché è una
parola che ci richiama qualcosa di
negativo come se fosse qualcosa di
brutto già sentirlo dire è spesso
utilizzato così ecco io vorrei togliere
questa appunto questo sapore e usarlo in
termini sociologici
tant'è che c'è proprio un sociologo
francese contemporaneo che appunto
allenerà berger che dice noi viviamo in
una società sociologicamente
individualista nel senso che è un
momento storico un'epoca in cui conta
molto di più
l'individuo della collettività e questo
di per sé non è una cosa brutta è stata
una conquista una conquista del
rinascimento dell'umanesimo
tutti noi abbiamo molta più cura di noi
siamo molto più attenti a ciò che ci fa
felice
ciò che ci piace quindi siamo
profondamente individuati quindi
l'individualismo è un tratto della
società contemporanea e non è detto che
l'individualismo sia di per sé egoismo
noi possiamo essere individualisti nel
senso di aver cura di noi e altruisti le
due cose stanno insieme
non vanno separate questo è importante
se no ci areniamo quindi dobbiamo
attraversare questi confini queste
categorie
quindi viviamo una società così è anche
una società in cui prevale la
competizione anche questo non vorrei
metterla in termini moralistici
io ho sempre amato lo sport mi piace
competere e bella l'elemento della
competizione perché ti tira fuori il
meglio di te e ti induce tirar fuori il
meglio di te
ecco semplicemente vorrei elogiare
qualcosa che c'è un po meno in una
società in cui c'è molto questo di cui
sappiamo anche i costi di tutto ciò il
costo dell'individualismo come quando
ogni cosa diventa troppo diventa
ipertrofica come quegli organi che si
gonfiano è la solitudine l'angoscia di
vivere il male di vivere uno dei grandi
miti dell'individuo punto dell'invito
dell'individualismo come felicità
individuale ea ritrovarsi soli con se
stessi quindi diciamo abbiamo bisogno
appunto di allenare l'altra parte quello
che parla di collaborazione e di
appunto solidarietà impegno con gli
altri ma come fatta esattamente la
collaborazione che cos'è che sa che
cos'è che sa di di meco di interessante
per noi la collaborazione un processo
sociale che ha appunto avviene con altri
non lo facciamo da soli e quindi
possiamo uscire dall'individualismo come
individui ma anche dall individualismo
come organizzazione
io lavoro in campo sociale e cerco di
facilitare il fatto che più persone più
organizzazioni possano cooperare
collaborare perché perché questo non
perché è giusto in sé ma perché più
efficace perché abbiamo problemi sociali
contemporanei sfide che appunto abbiamo
davanti a noi per cui ci serve quello
che tanti anni fa un filosofo alcuni
anni fa la nascita di internet un
filosofo francese pierre lévy appunto
chiamava intelligenza collettiva cioè
l'affermazione che molto ben
sintetizzata nessuno sa tutto
ognuno sa qualcosa quindi quando abbiamo
di fronte a noi un problema complesso
l'approccio individualista cioè fatto di
una singola persona o di una singola
organizzazione o anche di una singola
professione da riscaldamento climatico
alla denatalità al traffico al punto i
problemi sociali la povertà una sola
intelligenza una sola disciplina non ci
basta non è sufficiente ci serve
l'intelligenza collettiva
quindi abbiamo bisogno che queste cose
appunto dialoghi e come avviene avviene
sostanzialmente con cinque ingredienti
di questo cocktail diciamo di questa mix
la prima è una qualità intensa di
ascolto la collaborazione si nutre
dell'attesa del punto di vista
dell'altro quindi dobbiamo attraversare
il confine del nostro io e di centrarci
secondo elemento fondamentale per
lorenza collaborativa e il fatto di
approssimarsi a un punto di vista
diverso tentando di armonizzare gli
interessi che vanno mantenuti diversi
perché il rischio è che noi riusciamo
collaborare solo con coloro che la
pensano come noi ma la vera sfida della
collaborazione è quella di appunto
collaborare con chi è diverso da noi
per far questo c'è un tempo dell'attesa
l'altro deve entrare dentro di noi
l'altro come punto di vista come appunto
come visione del mondo
il terzo ingrediente è la tolleranza
abbiamo bisogno di legittimare
l'esistenza di un punto di vista altro è
anche di tollerarle anche qui in termini
cognitivi sopportare il rumore il
fastidio di un'idea dissonante ecco se
non riusciamo a reggere l'idea appunto
questo fastidio riusciamo a entrare in
contatto anche ad attraversare i confini
dei nostri schemi culturali dei nostri
modi di vedere il mondo con cui siamo
stati educati e entrare in contatto
verso un altro il quarto ingrediente è
il coordinamento di azioni e di
attenzioni perché la collaborazione
sentita la parola e soprattutto una
azione non è qualcosa che diciamo di
fare è qualcosa che riusciamo a fare e
quindi il fare l'azione è il banco di
prova della collaborazione e come
funziona questa azione
ecco funziona come una danza la
collaborazione è una interazione in cui
ci sincronizziamo come hanno fatto i
musicisti prima o come avviene con
un'orchestra o con una danza due come
nel tango
c'è una sincronizzazione di menti ed i
corpi tutti noi l'abbiamo sperimentato
quindi sono sicuro che dico qualcosa che
appunto in parte vi risuona ma la vera
sfida è quella di riuscire a farlo con
quelli con cui ci viene meno facile ed è
una fatica tendenzialmente ben
ricompensata perché si scopre
si inventa altro si produce bellezza si
sta meglio in una copia in una famiglia
punta in una in un'organizzazione in un
ambiente di lavora in una comunità
se riusciamo a compensare questo eccesso
di individualismo e di competizione
mitigandone gli aspetti meno nobili e
andando a rinforzare questo aspetto
collaborativo e da ultimo quinto
elemento quinto ecco quinto ingrediente
è la cole è che col è che la
collaborazione può essere facilitata se
l'ambiente in cui si realizza la cultura
l'organizzazione la legittima da un
punto di vista formale
noi abbiamo la costituzione la nostra
costituzione sono la legge da questo
punto di vista è una costituzione che
dice queste cose ma anche le piccole
costituzioni quotidiane quelle del modo
in cui funziona la nostra famiglia in
cui si collabora a fare le cose o del
nostro gruppo di amici in cui si
collabora o anche nel mondo del lavoro
sono delle aziende che non capita
talmente tanto bene che mitigano
mitigano proprio con le regole gli
eccessi della competizione perché sono
antiproduttivi non sono efficaci quindi
la collaborazione da questo punto di
vista anche conveniente è anche un
vantaggio competitivo
ecco potremmo usare questo paradosso se
un'organizzazione riesce a collaborare
riesce a competere meglio con altre
organizzazioni pensate per le piccole
aziende italiane per esempio e sono
molto piccole frammentate appunto si usa
dire che serve una cultura della
collaborazione di rete fare sistema sono
queste speciali quindi questo è
punto l'elogio che volevo fare l'invito
a può esercitare questa cosa nella
nostra vita nelle nostre vita personale
e lavorativa perché di questo credo ci
sia un gran bisogno ci sia un bisogno
ultimo ingrediente ultima cosa che mi
sento di dire da questo punto di vista è
l'attitudine al proprio a questa cultura
collaborativa qual è l'elemento che
possiamo riassumere in un motto che è
questo non collaborare solo se l'altro
collabora molte persone usano questa
espressione ma io collaborerei col mio
vicino il mio collega mio vicino di casa
con l'alta realtà l'altra azienda se lui
se lei se loro collaborare ecco chi
studia come me la collaborazione da
molti anni e ha dentro questi processi
sa che la che la collaborazione funziona
per anticipazione per anticipazione
quindi il motto qual è se vuoi
collaborare
devi ragionare in questo modo
collaborato affinché l'altro collabori
quindi dai tu il primo spazio aprite la
danza e tanti studi nelle neuroscienze
ci dicono fin dalla prima infanzia che
chi apre i giochi collaborativi a una
buona probabilità di avere poi un gioco
con collaborativo come risposta
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]